thank you very much everyone are you a
citizen of the United States of America
oh gee I'm sorry I just can't answer
that question and that's after spending
billions and billions of dollars there
used to be a time when you could answer
questions like that very easily there
used to be a time when you could proudly
declare I am a citizen of the United
States now they're trying to erase the
very existence of a very important word
and a very important thing citizenship
they're even coming after the Pledge of
Allegiance in Minnesota I'm proud to be
a citizen you're proud to be a citizen
the only people who are not proud to be
citizens are the ones who are fighting
us all the way about the word citizen
today I'm here to say we are not backing
down on our effort to determine the
citizenship status of the United States
population I stand before you to outline
new steps my administration is taking to
ensure that citizenship is counted so
that we know how many citizens we have
in the United States makes sense we will
defend the right of the American people
to know the full facts about the
population size of citizens and
non-citizens in America it is essential
that we have a clear breakdown of the
number of citizens and non-citizens that
make up the u.s. populations better
knowing this information is vital to
formulating sound public policy whether
the issue is health care education civil
rights or immigration we must have a
reliable count of how many citizens
non-citizens and illegal aliens are in
our country the Department of Commerce
sensibly decided to include a
citizenship question in the 2020 census
as has been done many many times
throughout
history of the United States
unfortunately this effort was delayed by
meritless litigation as shocking as it
may be far left Democrats in our country
are determined to conceal the number of
illegal aliens in our midst they
probably know the numbers far greater
much higher than anyone would have ever
believed before maybe that's why they
fight so hard this is part of a broader
left-wing effort to erode the rights of
the American citizen and is very unfair
to our country the Supreme Court
ultimately affirmed our right to ask the
citizenship question and very strongly
it was affirmed but the Supreme Court
also ruled that we must provide further
explanation that would have produced
even more litigation and considerable
time delays the case is already in three
federal district courts that have been
to be totally honest extremely
unfriendly to us these delays would have
prevented us from completing the census
on time it's deeply regrettable but it
will not stop us from collecting the
needed information and I think even in
greater detail and more accurately
therefore we are pursuing a new option
to ensure a complete and timely count of
the non citizen population today I will
be issuing an executive order to put
this very plan into effect immediately
I'm hereby ordering every Department and
agency in the federal government to
provide the Department of Commerce with
all requested records regarding the
number of citizens and non-citizens in
our country they must furnish all
legally accessible records in their
possession immediately we will utilize
these vast federal databases to gain a
full complete and accurate count of the
non citizen population including
databases maintained by the Department
of Homeland Security and the Social
Security Administration
we have great now
in many of our agencies we will leave no
stone unturned
the Census Bureau projected that using
previously available records it could
determine citizenship for 90% of our
population or more with today's
executive order which eliminates
long-standing obstacles to data sharing
we're aiming to count every one
ultimately this will allow us to have an
even more complete count of citizens
than through asking the single question
alone it will be we think far more
accurate the Census Bureau can use this
information along with information
collected through the questionnaire to
create the official census in other
words as a result of today's executive
order we will be able to ensure the 2020
census generates an accurate count of
how many citizens non-citizens
and illegal aliens are in the United
States of America not too much to ask
this will greatly inform a wide array of
public policy decisions this information
is also relevant to administering our
elections some states may want to draw a
state and local legislative districts
based upon the voter eligible population
indeed the same day the Supreme Court
handed down the census decision it also
said it would not review certain types
of districting decisions which could
encourage states to make such decisions
based on voter eligibility with today's
order we will collect all of the
information we need to conduct an
accurate census and to make responsible
decisions about public policy voting
rights and representation in Congress in
everything we do we will faithfully
represent the people of the United
States of America I would like now to
introduce Attorney General Bill Barr to
the podium thank you
good evening Thank You mr. president
and congratulations on today's executive
order which will ensure that we finally
have an accurate understanding of how
many citizens and non-citizens live in
our country as the Supreme Court
recognized it would be perfectly lawful
for the federal government to ask on the
census whether individuals are citizens
of the United States and it's entirely
reasonable to want to know how many
citizens and non-citizens there are in
the United States in fact the federal
government has routinely asked questions
relating to citizenship
ever since the 1820s but while the
Supreme Court correctly recognized that
it would be entirely appropriate to
include citizenship questions on the
census it nevertheless held that the
Commerce Department did not adequately
explain its decisions for doing so on
the 2020 census because as the Supreme
Court recognized the defect in the
Commerce Department's decision was
curable with a better record the
president asked me to work with
secretary Ross to determine whether
there remained a viable path for
including a citizenship question on the
census I did so in my view the
government has ample justification to
inquire about citizenship status on the
census and could plainly provide
rationales for doing so that would
satisfy the Supreme Court and there
therefore there is no question that a
new decision to add the question would
ultimately survive legal review the
problem is that any new decision would
be subject to immediate challenge as a
new claim in the three ongoing district
court cases in addition there are
injunctions currently in place that
forbid adding the question there is
simply no way to litigate these issues
and obtain relief from the current
injunctions in time to implement any new
decision without jeopardizing our
ability to carry out the census which
we're not going to do we're not going to
jeopardize our ability to carry out the
census so as a practical matter the
Supreme Court's decision closed all
paths to adding the question to the 2020
census put simply the impediment was not
it was a logistical impediment not a
legal one we simply cannot complete the
litigation in time to carry out the
census one other point on this some in
the media have been suggesting in the
historical mode of the day that the
administration has been planning to add
the citizenship question to the census
by executive Fiat without regard to
contrary court orders or what the
Supreme Court might say this has been
based on rank speculation and nothing
more should be obvious there has never
been under considers has never been
under consideration we have always
accepted that any new decision to add a
sense of citizenship question to the
census would be subject to judicial
review
turning to today I applaud the president
for recognizing in his executive order
that including a question on the census
is not the only way to obtain this vital
information the course the president has
chosen today will bring unprecedented
resources too big to bear on determining
how many citizens and non-citizens are
in our country and will yield the best
data the government has had on
citizenship in many decades that
information will be used for countless
purposes as the president explained in
his remarks today for example there is a
current dispute over whether illegal
aliens can be included for apportionment
purposes depending on the resolution of
that dispute this data may be
relevant to those considerations we will
be studying this issue congratulations
again mr. president on taking this
effective action
[Applause]